welcome to bananamores this next comic
is responsible for most of my wrinkles
caused by all the laugh lines
you think i was on the floor yeah
let's do it give it up for missy ladies
and gentlemen
that's here for yes
i'm excited to be here i'm excited uh
i'm excited to be out in general
uh because this pandemic is different
you're forced to be at home and deal
with your family
it's tough it's tough i'm a dad of three
um and i'm a husband to one allegedly
so that's always good uh have one wife
that's always a good thing
let's talk about these kids though um i
found out you know in this pandemic you
find out who's clean and who's
disgusting
uh kids are nice but they're nasty
uh kids are very nasty i love my babies
i do but i just found out how nasty
they are i found out how this whole
thing started it might have started in
my house
it may have started in my house and i
don't know because i was i was like the
other day right
here's a true story i was holding my
daughter i was holding my daughter
and out of nowhere you know her nose
running she she wipes her nose and she
just
grabs my lip just just snot and just
transfers it to my lip
immediately i forgot she was my baby i
dropped it ah
just dropped it it was don't feel bad
guys it was it was it was it was
something soft now i wouldn't she didn't
hit her head or anything
just she got to learn she got to learn
you can't you just can't go putting snot
on people's face
it's not it's not a typical practice
it's not a standard practice of mine
it's a different time though it's a
different age man where you got to wear
these masks
you got to know people by the eyebrows
you know i mean just walk around it's
like
dj is that you i know those eyebrows
anyway get over here how you doing boys
good to see you
good man you owe me some money i know
everybody before they actually get some
money from me hey hey hey let me see
eyebrows i'm gonna identify you okay
cool
see you out in public i wanna know who
you are good stuff
it's different time though was it was
once upon a time
where me as a black man going into a
bank wearing a mask was unheard of
now now it's welcome it's a great time
to be a bankroll right now
business is booming
he's like where's he at where's he at he
just ran past you with the mask on
everybody got a mask on everybody
it's an amazing time
uh i i grew up a little different than
most people though
i grew up a little different than most
people uh
my mom my mom had me when she was 13
years old
so it's pretty much the same age when
you really think about it um
i mean weren't too much we were doing
different like i couldn't drink she
couldn't drink
i couldn't go to the club she couldn't
go to club we're really doing the same
thing
um you ever went to the you ever went to
school with your mom
you ever done that that's weird like
attend school with your mother
teacher be like hey dj we're gonna tell
on you if you don't you don't get your
act together it's like
go get my mom she's the next class
we ride the same bus we got a whooping
together one time it was crazy it was
unheard of
never done it you you've never got a
whip until you got in the whooping with
the person who's supposed to be your
hero
we were holding hands
[Applause]
my mom said i'm gonna whoop you again
when we get done with this one for
getting me a whoopin
hey y'all i'm dj prior thank y'all this
kid's going places you heard me
clap it up for that incredible set